[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys und Samiras Welt!
Heute backen wir Burger Buns.
Ich habe ja schon
ein richtig gutes Burger-Bun-Rezept auf meinem Kanal.
Die formt man dann einfach frei aus der Hand.
Und sie werden wirklich perfekt!
Aber dann!
Dann kam was dazwischen.
Denn nach diesen Burger Buns
haben wir Kebabi kennengelernt,
in Karlsruhe unser Lieblingsdönerladen.
Und ich muss dazu sagen, dass der Ufuk abi,
der macht schon die besseren Brötchen.
Aber man muss dazusagen, es ist Dönerbrot.
Aber dann hatte ich so diese Vision,
dieses Brot, dieses fluffige, weiche Brot
als Burger umzufunktionieren.
Deswegen machen wir heute Burger Buns.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe mir ein paar Ticks
– Tipps und Tricks bei ihm abgeholt.
Also, wer aus Karlsruhe kommt, aus der Umgebung
oder irgendwann mal geschäftlich oder privat in Karlsruhe ist,
bitte probiert Kebabi Döner aus!
Es kann sein, dass ihr draußen ein bisschen warten müsst,
weil immer eine Warteschlange ist,
aber es ist wirklich der beste Döner.
Und es gibt ihn auch vegan.
Also probiert es einfach aus!
Vegan, vegetarisch, da gibt es alles.
Und alle sind sehr happy.
Jetzt probieren wir es aus.
Wir probieren die Kebabi-Brote
in megafluffig und luftig.
Dafür braucht ihr allerdings kleine Edelstahlringe,
also kleine Tortenringe sozusagen,
Burgerringe.
Denn darin werden sie gebacken.
Und der Hefeteig ist auch ein sehr flüssiger, weicher Hefeteig.
Dafür nehme ich einen Würfel Hefe,
300 Gramm warmes Wasser,
30 Gramm Zucker
und 30 Gramm Zuckerrübensirup,
300 Gramm Joghurt,
– das ist der 3,5%ige –
drei Eier,
900 Gramm Mehl,
– ich nehme ein 550er Mehl –
zwei Esslöffel Salz
und 100 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl.
Zuerst gebt ihr jetzt einfach die Hefe in die Rührschüssel.
Ihr könnt den Teig auch mit der Hand verkneten,
wie Samira schon sagte.
Aber
man sollte schon zehn Minuten kneten.
Von daher...
Ja, Wasser dazu.
>> SAMIRA: Dann da warmes Wasser rein.
Und jetzt muss die Hefe auftauen.
>> SALLY: Aufgelöst werden.
Das darfst auch du gleich machen.
>> SAMIRA: Und dann kommt noch der Zucker dazu.
>> SALLY: Hier, Zuckerrübensirup noch mit rein
und dann kurz verrühren.
Samira macht Satisfying Video Moments.
>> SAMIRA: Ach so, stimmt.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und den Rest kannst du so an den Rührhaken.
Yes!
Bis zum Schluss!
Du bist ein schwäbisches Mädel, das merke ich schon.
Bitte schön.
[Musik]
Uh! Jetzt hast du das alles am Finger.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das sieht etwas blutig aus.
Okay.
Jetzt ist ganz wichtig: Nicht direkt Salz oder Fett dazu geben,
sondern wirklich erst mal das Mehl,
damit die Hefe nicht durch Salz oder Fett
beeinträchtigt wird sozusagen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr aber wirklich alle Zutaten dazu geben,
den Teig kneten für etwa zehn Minuten.
Wenn ihr auch die Cooking Chef habt,
die Kenwood Cooking Chef,
dann gerne auch direkt mit etwas Hitze,
so 34°C.
Da wird die Hefe schon mal schön warm.
Du Quatschkopf!
[Musik]
Perfekt sieht der aus!
Guckt mal!
Und das ist jetzt wirklich ein schöner, flüssiger Teig,
der auch schön klebrig ist.
Und so muss er sein.
Denn ich möchte später einen richtig lockeren,
luftigen Burger Bun haben.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach den Knethaken raus,
decke den Teig ab.
Und ihr könnt ihn entweder an einem warmen Ort,
im Ofen zum Beispiel oder auch in der Maschine
oder bei Gärstufe bei 34°C, aufgehen lassen,
aber abgedeckt natürlich hier,
oder eben bei Raumtemperatur.
Und es kann jetzt sein, dass es eine Stunde geht oder zwei.
Es kann auch nur eine halbe Stunde dauern.
Achtet einfach darauf,
dass er wirklich bis mindestens auf das Doppelte aufgeht.
Der Hefeteig ist wunderbar aufgegangen.
Also der war jetzt wirklich tatsächlich bis hoch in die Schüssel
und bis hoch in die Maschine.
Kommt, ich zeige euch das mal.
Denn
ich habe nicht aufgepasst!
Also ich habe wirklich so nach einer Stunde
schon mal den Teig runtergedrückt.
Und dann ging er noch mal sofort hoch
und er ist mir bis in die Maschine rein gewachsen.
Jetzt macht ihr Folgendes:
Wirklich einfach alle Elemente wegnehmen,
den Teig trocknen lassen.
Denn, wenn ihr jetzt mit einem Tuch drangeht,
verschmiert ihr alles.
Also lasst ihr jetzt einfach alles trocknen.
Und wenn es trocken ist, lässt es sich einfach wegbürsten
entweder mit einem Tuch
oder mit einem Schwamm oder mit einer Bürste.
Und dann bekommt ihr alles wieder sauber.
Denn ich denke,
das kann schnell auch mal jedem passieren.
Upsi!
Ups!
Deswegen habe ich die so weggedreht,
dass ihr es nicht so seht.
Warum werden diese Burger Buns so fluffig?
Und heute erlaube ich mir wirklich,
ganz oft das Wort fluffig zu erwähnen.
Denn der Teig ist ja jetzt ganz flüssig
und wird jetzt praktisch in diese Ringe eingefüllt.
Das sind so Barbecue-Burger-Buns-Ringe.
Aber im Prinzip kann man damit
auch wunderbar kleine Törtchen backen.
Und die sind vom Durchmesser her
– wartet, ich sage es euch.
Durchmesser: 10,5 cm.
Also ich finde das auch eine perfekte Burger-Buns-Größe.
Und so kenne ich die halt auch vom Kebabi.
Also die sind da...
Dieses Brot dort, das ist einfach der Oberwahnsinn!
Und es gibt viele Menschen,
die einfach nur wegen dem Brot hinfahren.
Oder die holen sich dann einen Döner, stellen sich an
und kaufen dann noch mal so zehn Brote zum Einfrieren.
Die sind wirklich...
Also, Ufuk abi, ihr macht echt die besten Brote!
Muss ich wirklich, wirklich sagen.
Ich hoffe, meine werden jetzt genauso gut.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber
wir werden sehen.
Ich habe mir kurz überlegt, die Förmchen zu fetten.
Aber dann dachte ich mir: "Nein."
Bei Biskuitteig und Rührteig fette ich es ja auch nicht,
meine Tortenringe,
damit der Teig praktisch am Rand hochklettern kann
und nicht immer wieder so
so tschuck, tschuck zusammenfällt.
Ich probiere es jetzt einfach und wir werden sehen.
Und ich denke,
hier passen...
Ja.
Drei,
sechs,
neun.
Mh. Ich glaube, ich mache es so, sechs, sechs.
So.
Einer fehlt.
Wo ist der eine?
Den finde ich gleich noch.
Und ich denke, ich fülle sie jetzt
wirklich auch nur bis zur Hälfte,
damit der Teig noch mal Zeit hat zum Aufgehen.
Ich messe das jetzt hier ab.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt
die Schüssel mit dem Teig auf meiner Waage,
habe die auf null gesetzt
und schöpfe jetzt praktisch raus
und es geht dann ins Minus.
Und dann weiß ich einfach später auch ganz genau,
dass ich eben alles richtig habe.
Ich denke,
ich werde...
Ich habe jetzt hier
150 Gramm.
Ich bleibe mal dabei,
damit sie auch richtig schön luftig und locker werden.
Ihr könnt auch einen zweiten Schaber nehmen.
Ihr müsst nicht euren Finger nehmen.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
das macht doch Spaß.
[Musik]
Applaus für Samira,
das perfekte Klappenmädchen!
[Klatschen]
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Danke!
Tschau! Bis später!
Wisst ihr, es ist einfach...
Ich habe ja vorhin den Teig mal so Pi mal Daumen
mir so einfach theoretisch zusammengesucht.
Und dann gucke ich,
ich habe zwölf Ringe.
Und dann habe ich gesagt vorhin so:
"Ah, 150 Gramm pro Ring."
Und wenn dann der Teig einfach so exakt aufgeht,
ist das schon...
Da denke ich so: "Das ist doch ein Wunder!"
Es ist Augenmaß oder es war einfach Intuition.
Es sind
303 Gramm.
Also das heißt 150 und noch mal 150 Gramm.
Die Schüssel ist leer!
Es geht genau auf auf zwölf Stück!
Krass!
Wahrheit oder Lüge!
Kann es sein?
Ist es das?
Ist das, was Sie sehen, nur eine Illusion?
Oder ist diese Geschichte,
wie sie dieser Frau in Waghäusel widerfahren ist,
Wirklichkeit?
Entscheiden Sie selbst.
Ihr Jonathan Frakes.
Eigentlich wärst du der perfekte Jonathan Frakes.
>> SARAH: Ich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Weil ich pünktlich bin oder was?
>> SALLY: Weil du, Sarah,
bist ja so die Journalistin bei uns im Hause.
Wir erinnern uns zurück
an Sarah, die Journalistin.
[Musik]
[Feuerwehrsirenen]
>> SARAH: Breaking News aus Waghäusel.
Wir haben 12:35 Uhr und bei Sally ging der Rauchmelder an.
Wir sind natürlich live vor Ort
und können der besagten Sally ein paar Fragen stellen.
Sally, wie kam es dazu?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Was ist passiert?
>> SALLY: Es ging im Prinzip damit los,
ich habe den Ofen auf zehn Minuten eingestellt.
Da sahen die Kekse noch perfekt aus.
>> SARAH: Aha. Aha.
>> SALLY: Aber sie waren noch nicht durch.
Und ich habe sie noch mal fünf Minuten nachgestellt.
Und jetzt ist einfach...
[Musik]
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch tun werde,
ich möchte natürlich die Oberfläche glätten.
Und das geht natürlich etwas schwierig
mit so einem weichen Teig.
Das heißt, ich fette meine Hände mit Backtrennspray.
Ihr könnt aber auch Wasser nehmen.
Und ich hoffe,
dass die Oberfläche jetzt dadurch glatt genug wird.
Weil
das wäre etwas schade, wenn sie nicht so glatt wird.
Und die sehen jetzt übrigens ungleichmäßig gefüllt aus,
weil einfach der Teig schon wieder aufgegangen ist,
während ich hier noch
Quatsch gemacht habe.
Man muss schon sagen, wie es ist.
Oder vielleicht mache ich es auch so.
Bevor ich mir jetzt
eine Handmaske mache,
besprühe ich die Oberfläche
und glätte sie so.
Ich hoffe,
es klappt.
Aber ich sehe schon, der Teig,
der klettert jetzt schön am Rand hoch.
Also ich glaube,
dies könnte,
das könnte gut werden.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Brote erst mal so weit.
Und jetzt ist das Geheimnis:
Lasst sie wirklich schön lange ruhen,
bis sich die Form wieder füllt.
Ich muss jetzt einfach selber mal gucken,
ob jetzt eine halbe Stunde reicht
oder eine Stunde.
Ich hoffe, ich habe sie nicht zu voll gemacht,
sodass sie praktisch nicht gleich auslaufen.
Aber der...
Aber der Ufuk abi hat gesagt,
man muss sie lange aufgehen lassen.
Und
ich denke, das sollte ich jetzt auch tun.
Und ich hoffe, dass die 150 Gramm nicht zu viel waren.
Falls doch, mache ich es noch mal
und fülle sie mit 100 Gramm.
Habe ich auch kein Problem damit.
Dann mache ich es halt noch mal.
Wir probieren es aus. Okay?
Ich stelle sie jetzt einfach in den Backofen.
Ich glaube, die Gärstufe mache ich jetzt gar nicht,
sondern ich lasse sie wirklich so aufgehen,
dass ich für euch dann auch
die perfekte Gärzeit praktisch bestimmen kann.
Und dann gucken wir gleich, ob es klappt. Okay?
[Musik]
Ich hoffe, sie werden glatt
wie ein Babypopo!
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
[Musik]
Die Brote sind jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen.
Ihr hört schon, Ela ist jetzt auch mit dabei.
Eigentlich waren sie gerade...
Pst!
Eigentlich waren sie gerade perfekt aufgegangen,
aber ich musste dann Ela abholen im Kindergarten.
Deswegen sind die jetzt tatsächlich zu lange aufgegangen.
Also, wenn sie so sind,
so gerade an der Form, sind sie perfekt.
Ich habe es jetzt hier aber einfach so gemacht.
Ist jetzt auch, finde ich, gar nicht so schlimm.
Also zum einen muss ich sie auseinanderschieben.
Das hätte ich vorhin schon tun sollen.
Und zum anderen
– ich will ja jetzt nicht, dass sie beim Backen überlaufen –
mache ich einfach jetzt so.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Und wir probieren es jetzt einfach.
Wir probieren es.
>> ELA: Mama, kannst du mir helfen?
So ganz vorsichtig zurück.
Und wir gucken einfach,
wie sie gleich fertig gebacken aussehen.
Ich helfe dir sofort, Schatz.
>> ELA: Mama, Mama!
>> SAMIRA: Was habe ich hier jetzt noch mal?
>> SALLY: Und du hast ein Ei mit zwei Esslöffeln Milch.
Nee, ein bisschen mehr.
Ein Ei mit vier Esslöffeln Milch
hat Samira gerade verquirlt.
>> ELA: Ich wollte auch!
>> SALLY: Ja, darfst gleich helfen.
>> ELA: Darf ich gleich...
>> SALLY: Du musst aber erst mal deine Händchen waschen.
>> ELA: Okay, ich wasche meine Händchen hier vorne.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt ganz vorsichtig.
Weil wir wollen ja jetzt das Brot nicht zerdrücken.
Wirklich so leicht.
Eigentlich bräuchten wir jetzt so eine Sprühflasche.
>> ELA: Mama, ich habe meine Hände gewaschen.
>> SALLY: Super hast du das gemacht!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe verstanden,
sie hat ihr Handy gewaschen.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, eine Blase!
Warte. Ich mache das eine Blech mal fertig.
Dann können wir tauschen.
Dann seid ihr beide beschäftigt.
Genau, dann kannst du nämlich von der Ela weg.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, Ela,
du machst das Streichen und ich bestreue.
>> SALLY: Nee, nee. Komm. Hier, du darfst...
Oder wollt ihr beide streuen?
>> SAMIRA: Nee, ich streue und Ela streicht.
>> SALLY: Nee, Ela kann nicht streichen.
Das ist eine Aufgabe für große Mädels.
Guck mal, Ela. Jetzt ganz wenig nehmen
und so, ja?
So.
Und Samira macht dann
Sesam.
Also Sesam und Schwarzkümmel haben wir jetzt hier.
[Musik]
Ihr macht das super!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe gedacht, das ist Mohn.
>> SALLY: Nee, Mohn ist ein bisschen blau
und Schwarzkümmel ist so schwarz.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich bin jetzt echt richtig, richtig gespannt,
wie das klappt und wie das dann gleich aussieht.
Und
so.
Und jetzt müssen sie direkt in den vorgeheizten Backofen,
gleich heiß gebacken werden.
Und wir drücken einfach die Daumen,
– ja? –
dass es klappt.
Ich glaube, ich backe jetzt einfach beide bei
– nee, ich mache Ober-/Unterhitze.
[Musik]
Samira, guck mal. Wie sehen die Brötchen aus bitte?
>> SAMIRA: Cool!
>> SALLY: Schon gut, gell?
Die sind schon gut geworden.
Wir decken sie jetzt ab
und lassen sie ruhen,
lösen sie später aus dem Ring.
Und daraus machen wir coole Burger.
Aber nicht in diesem Video.
Aber in diesem Video zeige ich euch noch,
wie sie aussehen im Innern.
[Musik]
Also ich muss ja echt sagen,
ich habe die ja noch mal gemacht
und dann wirklich nicht zu lange aufgehen lassen,
sodass sie eben nicht über diesen Ring schauen,
und dann direkt gebacken
und die sind wirklich perfekt.
Also 150 Gramm,
ideal!
Ich habe auch gerade noch
– schaut mal –
ein Blech gemacht mit 100 Gramm.
Hoppala!
Autschi!
War ein bisschen heiß.
Sind auch gut.
Also die sind nicht ganz so hoch.
Aber ich bin Fan von diesen 150-Gramm-Burgern.
Ich hatte nur vorhin die Wahl zwischen:
Backe ich jetzt die Burger
und die werden perfekt
oder hole ich mein Kind vom Kindergarten ab?
Also habe ich doch die Ela lieber vom Kindergarten abgeholt.
Aber, wie gesagt, 150 Gramm, perfekte Burger Buns!
Ich bin ein Fan!
Und jetzt habe ich sie einfach kurz abkühlen lassen,
so etwa zehn, zwanzig Minuten.
Draußen kommt ein Sturm auf.
Egal.
Und dann kann man sie auch ideal
mit so einer Palette rauslösen
und dann auf einem Kuchengitter abkühlen lassen.
Schön!
Richtig schön!
[Musik]
Also hier sind die fertigen Burgerbrötchen.
Ich habe sie jetzt einfach rausgelöst
und
abgedeckt mit einem Tuch,
damit sie schön abkühlen.
Und jetzt probieren wir sie einfach.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber aussehen tun sie schon irgendwie cool, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also ich könnte mir jetzt gut vorstellen,
dass da ein Burger ziemlich cool aussieht.
Also dann aufschneiden.
Und wenn ich jetzt den Burger belege,
würde ich ihn natürlich erst einmal noch angrillen.
Und willst du oben oder unten probieren?
Oder so ein Stück abreißen?
>> SAMIRA: Ich nehme das unten.
Ich auch.
Josh, du auch?
>> JOSH: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss schon sagen
– guck mal!
>> JOSH: Komm, ich probiere mal von oben,
wenn ihr beide unten habt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Guck mal, diese Konsistenz!
>> SAMIRA: Auch nicht zu salzig.
>> SALLY: Also die sind schon
also zum einen krass saftig,
richtig saftig,
ganz weich und fluffig.
>> SAMIRA: Ich wollte gerade sagen, richtig fluffig.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Auch nicht zu salzig.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> SAMIRA: Süß ist er auch nicht.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Richtig, richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Also wir werden daraus einen Burger zaubern.
Wie wäre es mit einem Sommerburger?
>> SAMIRA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Summer Burger!
Das machen wir.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt,
wie wir diesen Summer Burger machen,
dann schaltet einfach das nächste Mal ein.
Da machen wir den Burger.
Und jetzt habt ihr hier ein Grundrezept
für leckere Burger Buns aus dem Burgerring.
Also viel Spaß beim Machen...
Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Hey, vielleicht können wir die noch
in vegan machen.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann einen veganen Burger.
Wenn ja, dann schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Tschüss!
Hm.
Nicht schlecht!
Und man kann sie super einfrieren!
Einfrieren,
auftauen, aufbacken,
perfekt!
[Musik]